ok I'm back and I just have to finish up
problem number 18 I just want to make
sure i did is 10 minus x squared right
right this will be x squared minus 20x
plus 100 plus 225 I just want to make
sure this is where I always mess up so
then let's see what's 325 minus 2 89 see
it's 25 plus 11 right so it's 36 so we
where you're left with 0 is equal to x
squared minus 20x plus 36 and now we
just have to factor this right here and
let me let me I'll do it up here so 0
confuse you when I go all the way up
here but 0 is equal so what two numbers
when you multiply them is equal to 36
and when you add or subtract them you
get minus 20 let's see what do you get
let's see 12 and 12 and 3 now 18 18 and
2 18 times two is 36 and if you do make
them both negative when they add to go
to negative 20 so if we do so that's X
minus 18 and X minus 2 right I just
factored this as X minus 18 and X minus
2 and you can review the my presentation
on factoring quadratics if you forgot
how to do this but I just said well 18
times two is 36 and they have to be
negative because when they add together
you get minus 20 so X could be equal to
18 or X could be equal to 2 and those
are the possible choices and that's it
this was a short video just the left
over for problem number 18 I'll see you
in the next second